-Guys, we made it
to the weekend!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
It was a crazy week
in the news.
Everybody's still talking
about President Trump's
Russia comments.
But in an interview on CBS,
Trump said that
he now holds Vladimir Putin
personally responsible
for election interference.
Yeah.
Then Trump paused and said,
[ As Trump ] "They don't get
this show in Russia, right?
[ Laughter ]
They can't see that? Okay."
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump said he wants to have
another meeting with Putin.
And this time, he wants
to host Putin in Washington.
Then Melania was like,
"He can have my room."
And he goes -- Hold on.
[ Applause ]
Director of National
Intelligence Dan Coats
found out during
a live interview
that Putin might visit.
Trump said, "Next time,
I'll have my people call
your people."
And then Coats was like,
"Mr. President,
I am your people.
I'm the one --"
[ Laughter ]
What?
"Tell me what's going on!"
Did you guys see this?
The newest issue
of "Time" magazine
just came out,
and the cover features
Trump and Putin's faces
blended together.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Light laughter ]
When he saw that,
Trump was like,
[ As Trump ] "I've never seen
a more beautiful creature
like that in my entire life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow."
[ Applause ]
And the cover's headline says,
"The Summit Crisis,"
but they actually thought about
using a different headline
for that photo.
Take a look.
It was almost, "Chicken Born
Without Feathers on Face."
-Wow.
-"Time" magazine?
[ Applause ]
-Wow.
-It seems odd.
-Rude!
-Get this.
Microsoft said
they actually caught Russia
trying to meddle
in the midterm elections.
Microsoft, yeah.
Russians knew they were busted
when Clippy the Paperclip
popped up and said,
"Looks like you're trying
to hack an election!"
They go, "Thank you, Clippy."
[ Applause ]
I heard that Trump wants to give
Air Force One a makeover.
You can tell he's serious,
'cause today he asked the cast
of "Queer Eye"
if they do planes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys, I read
that more American families
are only having two kids,
which means they're aren't
as many middle children.
Yeah.
It's all a part of the plan
to make middle children feel
even more left out.
[ Laughter ]
It's sad.
[ Applause ]
And finally,
the US Census Bureau
found that couples often lie
about their incomes
when women make more
than their husbands.
In response, Jay-Z was like,
"Why's everyone looking at me?"
Guys, we have
a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!